um everyone wants to know about defy
uh they see all kinds of crazy things on
twitter
uh you probably understand it better
than most what is defy
and what's happening over the last you
know 60 days in the d5 market
yeah now it's a great question so d5 is
basically
a way it's it's trying to replicate
services and financial markets
um without the intermediary that's
taking
the rent or or or or creating like some
some level of uh
it's it's like the centralized entity
that's removing transparency and so
you have these issues that that are kind
of of the similar ethos as bitcoin
it's all under that idea it's just more
specific more targeted and so what's
great is these aren't necessarily
competing with bitcoin you know
these aren't these d5 projects aren't
going to become stores of value
their value is a function of the amount
of fees and productive
value they can provide so what you're
starting to actually see some kind of
fundamental way to think about these
things and
and d5 has been around for quite some
time it's just it hasn't really taken
off until recently so
and it's it was it exists in 2018 2019
and and over time it's just become kind
of
more complex in terms of what people are
building so initially it was a lot of
borrowing and lending and so the idea
was i have this money i can
post as collateral and i take a
massively over collateralized loan and
now i have this capital they can do
things with
and if you think about like the the
smart contracts necessary
to do something like that they're a bit
more simple because there's not a lot of
interaction it's
the main interaction is provide
collateral withdrawal
other asset and now you're out of the
system so as
the development of of these systems has
kind of grown the use cases have evolved
with them and so
what we've seen recently um
was it was a combination of things so
you know after the
the large sell-off in march everything
kind of bounced back
and that's when you really saw d5 start
to to blow up a lot
and it was a combination of things so on
one end you had
several d5 projects that were either
launching
um providing new products uh v2s
updates and and trying to basically
optimize their structure
and at the same time um and this side is
a bit more anecdotal where
um you had some institutions come into
the space that were basically
um almost suppressing bitcoin volatility
so they were they were coming in
and their whole goal was to provide
yields they were they were exercising
cover call strategies where they would
you know hold spot sell sell calls
and um they would just create a yield
that way and they were really
agnostic to the price of bitcoin but
more so just trying to generate a yield
and so
what that would do is that would flood
the market with a lot of calls and at
the same time
um you'd have some market neutral desks
or others that would
basically buy those calls on the cheap
and then sell spot to
to kind of offset that to create that
hedge and and so that kind of
really dampened bitcoin volatility where
we saw bitcoin was really flat from you
know
uh end of april or like may until mid to
late june
and during that time we also saw
defense start to pick up and so it was a
really interesting combination of the
two where
now you're starting like bitcoin holders
are are
you know a lot of them trade leverage
and and use options and so
when bitcoin is just bouncing between 92
and 96 or 97 for a month and a half they
they're losing their mind and so
at the same time they're seeing d5 as
gaining 100
a week and a bunch of these assets and
so
their interests start to pour over as
well and so you started to see a lot
more
um attention focus on the devices
because that's where the returns were
and to an extent you can think of it
it's like there you know some people
think of it as
a bubble but realistically if you think
about the size of
d5 right now it's still less than a
ripple or xrp and so like
it's not a bubble in the same way that
we saw 2017 where
everything was running and and so you
had like you know billions and billions
of artificial value created
here it's a very small set of of a
handful of names and that's why at the
same time
the amount of capital that flows into
them causes their price to even
to move up even even further and so
what's been useful is it
has brought a lot of attention to the
space and created um
a lot of a lot of natural i guess demand
and so
what some of these d5 projects are
creating are so
it's it's intricate yield generating uh
mechanisms so you had the whole
liquidity mining um
fiasco that that will you know only
continue but but
like continue to improve and so
initially liquidity mining is basically
i need you i want you to provide
liquidity for this project
and and or or basically post your assets
and and generate a yield and normally
the yield you'd get
was a function of how much people wanted
to borrow it but now it's
we supplement it with our token and so
the token
now you know users aren't getting seven
eight percent they're getting fifteen
hundred percent or a thousand percent
yield on their assets and so
that doesn't happen how does that happen
i think that's what people are confused
by right they hear a thousand percent
yield on something and they're like
this has got to be a scam right so like
explain how
like something like that happens and and
then we talk about like yield farming
and all that
yeah absolutely so it's it's that value
is annualized
and the reason it ends up ballooning is
you'll have these projects that
they'll let's just say they have a
thousand tokens they'll only distribute
you know a small amount at first and
it's kind of like a leaking faucet where
they'll distribute that gradually
and what happens is as those tokens get
get distributed the the idea is at the
same time they're
looking to incorporate ways that those
tokens will have value in the future
and so part of those is a function of
governance and then
within governance you can um structure
it's such that a certain amount of the
fees from the entire protocol go to
those tokens so
the way what happens is they start to
issue a few tokens but those tokens
start to balloon in price
and their schedule is still to
distribute
one token a day you know but just as a
scale
but that token initially started at 30
cents and now it's at
40 bucks and so the yield has just gone
insane and like your the capital you're
providing is still the same and so what
happens is
a lot of money floods into there because
you know these markets want to normalize
that yield and say i'm going to take it
and eventually they kind of come down
but
for extended periods for weeks at a time
you know there's people farming
with like four digit yields which is
absurd and and
obviously it's not going to be
sustainable forever but the idea there
in the long
run is that so the fear is
and and kind of the the way you can
differentiate some good from some bad
projects with yield farming is
okay once that yield farming stops how
much
what portion of these assets will
actually remain with that project and
how many will just
you know opportunistically jump to the
next situation where there's the most
heal farming
and it almost makes it tough because
projects won't all debut at the same
time so
even if you're a project where you have
a natural amount of yield that you can
generate the problem is if somebody else
launches after you
that can then just provide that yield
it's like even if i like what i'm
getting here and
you know holding all else constant your
project will generate me a higher yield
it still makes sense for me to move my
assets somewhere else and capture that
and then eventually move back
and so that's kind of where the the
yield farming craze is happening but
um it's it's just understanding yeah
which projects will do the best job of
retaining that capital
and then at the same time how can they
leverage that capital to
um generate actual fees so not fees that
are
inflated by the they're just issuance of
the token but from
providing a product that's actually
useful and so that's where
things kind of get interesting and and
really seeing how this whole um
space will shake out